bill having gone on auditions for years
and maybe
not knowing why you didn't get a part
then you become a filmmaker
and now you sit on that other side of
the desk
do you let potential actors or
documentary subjects know why they
didn't get apart
why why not you always hear actors are
so frustrated because they never know
what it was
it could have been nothing personal just
somebody's height
they weren't a good match as someone's
daughter whatever it was but
do you let actors know or you know that
that's just part of the business that's
just protocol
somebody calls me and wants to talk to
me i'll tell the truth
but most people go away and they take it
personally
it's not personal it's just a cruel
rejecting business
i mean i mean even if you come in and
you're right for the part
i i was i was i was a filmmaker
named the film but i was directing this
film for a studio once
and the the head of the studio sitting
here
and the head of marketing was here and
here's me
we're going through a file of actors
pictures and stuff
and i'm talking about
how good the actor is and how he's right
for the part
and the executive looks at me and he
looks at
the marketing person and he says oh you
like this right
marking princesses no global
i learned so fast because
it had something to do with the actors
but if they had no global audience
they're not going to be in the film they
could have they could have done the
greatest audition
for that part but they bring no business
and the actor goes home and says i was
great
and they rejected me maybe i'm not so
good no you're brilliant you were the
best
guy for the part but no global